as a football star you had uh certain
fans a lot of fans but a certain type of
fan and then you start doing this
morning show and suddenly you have
completely different uh cross-section of
people that are that are seeing you
you've got uh older ladies watching who
probably didn't know you as well when
you were a football star yeah I mean the
crazy thing is I don't think most people
realize I play football now right yeah I
mean it's the thing all the guys you
know the guys come up and you're like
yeah yeah Michael straigh hand yeah
thank you for beating the Patriots and
Super Bowl man we appreciate it let's
not mention that okay okay I'm sorry
about that don't show that snake don't
show that snake video all right all
right all right I had so um you know and
it was like great but now the same guys
hey Michael straight hand I'm like yeah
you know football they go we love you
with Kelly and I'm oh yeah but they
don't even realize that I played but to
me it's a compliment yeah it's a
compliment you've reinvented yourself
which is a very hard thing to do well
I've always kind of been the same but
I'm just in a different medium right you
have you get kids now little kids who
see you uh on the show and they send in
fan mail a kid sent in this drawing I
don't know how you feel about this
drawing look at the eyes and the
eyes first of all what medication are
you
on look how he went out of his this kid
went out of his way to draw the teeth
you know they never you know what it
could be the photo could look nothing
like me but the teeth are always correct
it never mess up
the never mess up the tee kids are very
conscious of that but kids are also very
honest like sit there with a kid and go
oh you're missing a tooth and I'm no
just never came never there sorry kid uh
okay uh I'm curious about the uh the
Kids Choice sports award you're hosting
this and this is is this the event where
you get slimed you get slime yeah a lot
of slime I've never I've always thought
uh I've never been slimed we can make it
happen well I'm working I'm working with
sesi now
uh my sliming days are over but uh but
what is that stuff I always thought like
is is that like a toxic goo what is it
no it it actually it doesn't taste bad
it kind of tastes like um you're not
supposed to eat it no but if you've been
SL it's good it gets in your mouth a
little bit it's like green apple okay
but it is really gooey and sticky and
like days later you'll be showering you
you'll scrub yourself to death and then
days later there'll be some green stuff
that falls off in the shower and you go
where like where did it come from I got
everywhere I knew possible wonder where
that came from yeah they slimed me but
it's great going to be a great show it
it's all the the favorite athletes voted
on by the kids great and um we're giving
U David Beckham's getting our Legends
award that's cool and Kevin Durant
Russell Wilson we have so many um
incredible players who are going to come
out athletes and then of course fors
going to perform and make us happier
than we'll already be at the end of the
night sounds fantastic sounds like a
great show I want to mention one thing
an amazing honor NFL Hall of Fame
induction
for you is next month an amazing honor
congratulations when this happens when
that actual moment happens and you're up
there and you're talking do you think
you're going to shed a tears I don't
know man I'm not a crier but one thing
that does make me Cryer like these
Sports movies or like that movie babe
with the pig yeah and no it's not like
okay you know a part of Babe made me
every time I think about I almost come
to tears but um when the pig is finished
and the pig is like happy wants to do it
again and the owner goes that'll do pig
that'll do right it was kind of like
when I was going to retire my dad said
you've done well son you've done well I
felt like I'm glad he didn't say that'll
do that's the way I feel though I'm
going to be able to get speech and this
is something I played because I love to
play I never thought about the Hall of
Fame and I played because I wanted to
make my parents proud so if I'm speaking
I don't know if I'm going to be able to
make eye contact it's kind of like being
around some stars in Hollywood you can't
look them directly in the
I may not have to be able to look at my
dad like Direct in the eye CU it may
made me make me cry and I don't want to
cry right well you know what it it's an
incredible
honor